[Music]
I'm Molly bloom do you know about me
where's your indictment after I got your
call last night and I bought your book
do you understand that you are charged
with operating an illegal gambling
business are you taking me on as a claim
I don't think I can convince my partners
to take a flyer on polar princess if you
think a princess can do it I did you're
incorrect I'm getting it you don't think
much of me but what if every single one
of your ill-informed
unsophisticated pinions that moving on
I'd be amazed this is a true story
except for my own and I changed all the
names hey Molly my weekly poker game is
moved to the Cobra lodge you'll help run
it I was in a room with movie stars
directors and business Titans they were
going all-in all the time - wrong
message for you thank you so much
[Music]
I'm gonna stop being my assistant I'm
not firing you're just gonna stop paying
you get paid once a week from the game
it doesn't seem fair you're gonna stop
paying because I'm making too much money
doing my second job and if I say no lose
both jobs because it doesn't seem fair
you're doing a bargaining power here you
are unimportant you know any witches
were burned on sale
how many none they didn't burn which was
it's a myth they hanged him The
humiliation had given way to blinding
anger at my powerlessness I wasn't gonna
wait before I put a plan in place I'll
be hosting a game in this suite every
Tuesday night first buy-in 250,000
that's gonna make noise we spent eight
years in Hollywood but then two years in
New York burning the world's most
exclusive and decadent mancave
have you seen the other names in your
indictment come on Marty just out deep
into the Russian mob where you hear
exposures crazy and got 2.8 billion on
this drink right now you're gonna get
blown up you managed to build a
multi-million dollar business using not
much more than their whips I'm about to
be charged in federal court well
nobody's perfect
there's a new offer and it's a complete
immunity we hand over the hard drive you
see what's on his hard drives family's
lives careers will be ruined
why Ewing this alone where are the
people you're protecting by not to the
whole story I'll tell them everything
they want to know about me about me
[Music]